so sieht es aus wenn einem der
berüchtigsten verbrecher deutschlands
der prozess gemacht wird das kölner
landgericht wird zu einem
hochsicherheitstrakt mit spürhunden
durchsuchten polizeibeamte jeden winkel
ein wahnsinniger aufwand und das alles
nur wegen ihm
reemtsma-entführer thomas drach hier in
nordrhein westfalen wird dem 61-jährigen
heute der prozess am kölner landgericht
gemacht und die anklage diesmal lautet
schwerer raub brandstiftung und
versuchter mord ja das alles ist aber
nichts neues für den mann der in seinem
leben offenbar nur eines gelernt hat
verbrechen zu begehen und das schon seit
seiner jugend
seine flucht endete 1998 zwei jahre
nachdem er 30 millionen mark lösegeld
erbeutet eine spektakuläre flucht endet
mit einem telefonat dass drach mit einem
ehemaligen gefängnisinsassen führt die
polizei hört mit und stürmt mitten in
der nacht sein hotel mit 13 bricht er
sein erstes auto auf 1981 überfällt er
mit seinem bruder lutz eine sparkasse in
köln dafür muss tracht für sieben jahre
in den knast
1996 kommt dann das ganz große ding in
sachen komplizen kidnappen dem millionär
jan philipp reemtsma
die bande macht ernst sie hinterlassen
eine lösegeldforderung und beschweren
sie mit einer echten handgranate
33 tage sitzt dreht es mal angekettet in
einem berliner keller muss um sein leben
fürchten nach der geldübergabe lässt die
verbrecherbande den millionär laufen ein
lösegeld von 30 millionen mark
umgerechnet rund 15 millionen euro
drach setzt sich nach uruguay ab und
bietet eine villa sein geld gibt dafür
autos frauen und drogen aus einen teil
des geldes versteckt der in belgien und
in tonnen an der a3 zwei jahre lang
bleibt unentdeckt doch dann wird ihr
telefonat zum verhängnis während er mit
seiner freundin in argentinien urlaub
macht von einem hotelzimmer in buenos
aires aus ruft er einen kumpel an mit
dem er zusammen im knast gesessen hat
die polizei hat mit und stürmt nachts um
halb zwei das hotelzimmer drach ist
gefasst er wird nach deutschland
ausgeliefert kommt für 14 eineinhalb
jahre in den knast
2013 hat er schließlich seine strafe
abgesessen nun braucht er an scheingeld
2018 und 2019 sollen dann mindestens
drei geldtransporter überfallen haben
für diese taten muss er nun vor den
richter um 9 uhr 15 startet der
druckprozess und dafür wird das kölner
landgericht zum hochsicherheitstrakt bei
einer verurteilung droht bout eine
lebenslange haft durch seine vorstrafen
müsste er dann bis zu seinem tod hinter
gittern und
bild reporter tim spector beobachtet
diesen prozess für uns und vor wenigen
minuten ist drach ja nun angekommen
unter extremen sicherheitsvorkehrungen
erklären wie das ganze genau abgelaufen
ist was hat man da gesehen
ja der ursprüngliche plan der sei
eigentlich so aus dass man thomas tracht
mit einem helikopter aus der jva in
ossendorf dass ein stadtteil ungefähr
sieben kilometer luftlinie von hier aus
vom landgericht ausgesehen hierüber
fliegen wollte diesen plan hat man dann
aber doch wieder verworfen vermutlich
weil es doch noch windig ist heute
morgen man hat den thomas trachte mit
einer bmw kolonne drei bmw sind dann
hierüber gerast herübergebracht schwer
bewacht ist er natürlich geworden man
hat ihn dann von hinten hier ins gericht
eingefahren dort haben ihn dann sek
beamte in empfang genommen und hoch bis
zum saal gebracht wir können das einmal
kurz zeigen das ist saal 112 hier hinter
mir
dort oben sollte dann eigentlich um 9
uhr 15 der prozess starten der prozess
ist jetzt noch ein bisschen nach hin
verlegt worden weil eben die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen so hoch sind
dass zahlreiche zuschauer und
journalisten noch nicht im saal sind die
werden noch kontrolliert und dann gehts
eben
in ungefähr einer viertelstunde haben
wir eben gehört los wir hören dass
thomas drach schon im saal ist er soll
entspannt wirken er trägt sakko pulli
und jeans blättert in unterlagen und ist
wahrscheinlich selber auch gespannt
darauf dass es dann endlich los geht
du hast gerade gesagt dass aufgrund der
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sich der prozess
also verzögert welche maßnahmen wurden
getroffen rund um das gericht und vor
allen auch im gericht
vielleicht fangen wir mal mit dem an was
man mit thomas drach sozusagen gemacht
hat der muss heute morgen erstmal ein
crooner schnelltest machen dann sind
seine klamotten die er sich übrigens
selber aussuchen durfte die hat einen
anwalt im land gegeben die sind erst mal
händisch durchsucht worden dann auch
noch mal geräumt worden wenn man eben
verhindern wollte dass er zum beispiel
ein messer oder ähnliche waffen mit in
dem saal bringt man hat ihm dann hand
und fußfesseln angelegt und auch noch
eine art mütze über dir die augen
gezogen damit er sich überhaupt nicht
orientieren kann damit überhaupt nicht
weiß wo genau er denn hin gebracht wird
und ja hier im gerichtssaal selber
müssen die zuschauer heute durch zwei
sicherheitskontrollen normalerweise ist
ja nur eine diesmal geht man auf nummer
sicher und hat noch eine zweite
installiert sozusagen und auch rund ums
gericht hat man heute so ein bisschen
das gefühl als käme der us-präsident
oder sonst ein hochrangiger politiker
zum beispiel sind hier viele straßen
gesperrt worden es stehen viele viele
schwer bewaffnete polizisten rund um
dieses gebäude und ein interessantes
detail auch man hat hier die gullydeckel
rund ums gebäude zugeschweißt schon vor
tagen der hintergrund ist der dass man
eben eine befreiungsaktion befürchtet
und daneben befürchtet hat auch das
komplizen zum beispiel sprengsätze an
diesen gullydeckeln befestigen könnten
wie geht es denn jetzt heute genau
weiter wie ist dieser tag geplant am
gericht
ja wenn es denn gleich endlich losgeht
dann wird vermutlich erst einmal die
anklage verlesen die hat es ja schon in
sich dann rechnet man damit dass
vielleicht auch noch ein antrag oder
zwei von der verteidigung gestellt
werden er wird dann wahrscheinlich noch
etwas zu mittag essen bekommen hier im
gericht und dann geht es dann eben
irgendwann wieder schwer bewaffnet
schwer beschützt zurück in die jva das
ganze wird übrigens 53 mal passieren so
oft ist angesetzt und da kann man sich
schon vorstellen was das für ein riesen
aufwand ist aber heute wird es
vermutlich erst einmal darum gehen die
komplette anlage zu verlesen tim vielen
dank für den moment du hälst uns weiter
auf dem laufenden vor dem landgericht in
köln mit dem steckt
und wir schauen weiter zu bild
chefreporter frank schneider der
verfolgt nämlich die taten dieses man
ist schon seit sehr vielen jahren was
macht tatsächlich so gefährlich frank
ja was macht sie so gefährlich man muss
sich überlegen er hat von seinem leben
über 20 jahre hinter gittern verbracht
er ist wirklich was man so klassisch
nennt ein berufsverbrecher das gehört
für ihn auch zum berufsrisiko dazu eben
mal ins gefängnis zu kommen wenn es denn
schief geht das versuchte natürlich zu
verhindern er selber sieht sich auch als
eine art kriminelles superhirn er sieht
sich selber als eine der großen cleveren
gangster die es gibt und er glaubt eben
auch in seiner selbstherrlichkeit er
könne eigentlich machen was er wolle er
glaubt auch jetzt wohl immer noch an den
freispruch so hört man jedenfalls aus
seinem umfeld und es ist immer so
gewesen dass er egal was er gemacht hat
immer der meinung war das ist richtig so
er hat walker kein schuldgefühl dafür
kann kein schuldeingeständnis von ihm
hat man niemals gehört er hat damals
reden zwar vor gericht sogar gesagt er
solle doch dankbar sein dass er so gut
behandelt worden wäre und in dieser
nacht in diesem nazismus das sagt noch
damals schon die gutachter im prozess
geht von ihm natürlich eine hohe
gefährlichkeit aus weil überhaupt nicht
einsieht was er da tut und er glaubt
eben auch tatbeute steht ihm zuhört auch
damals nach der entführung gedacht oder
auch über äußert gegenüber dem gutachter
diese beute die noch irgendwo liegt die
stände ihm zu er habe ja dafür sozusagen
eine schwere straftat begangen und das
sei ja sozusagen seine entlohnung und
der renesmee gutachter in dem prozess
muss man wirklich sagen der hatte damals
schon sehr große weitsicht er hat gesagt
wenn der wieder raus kommt der wird mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit wieder schwere
straftaten begehen ohne rücksicht auf
verluste skrupellos eiskalt kaltblütig
und wird auch wieder das leben anderer
menschen gefährden und da muss man sagen
hat er ja auf dramatische art und weise
recht behalten denn zwei geldboten
hätten fast die tat mit dem leben
bezahlt er hat zwar nur in
anführungsstrichen in die beine
geschossen aber einer hatte so ein
großes verletztes blutgefäß im bein dass
er haaresbreite verblutet wäre damals
frank kurze fragen ob du hast gesagt
thomas drach glaubt an einen freispruch
realistisch ist dass er nicht oder
nein überhaupt nicht es gibt sehr gute
beweise es gibt auch eine dna
mischspuren der anwalt sagt natürlich
das sind nur indizien aber die sind
schon sehr erdrückend und es geht jetzt
hier in diesem prozess natürlich für ihn
um alles die sicherungsverwahrung steht
im raum die lebenslange haftstrafe ist
das eine aber wegen versuchten mordes
aber die sicherungsverwahrung erst 61
und er hat einfach keine zeit mehr und
das weiß er und deshalb ist auch die
große gefahr dass er vielleicht
ausbrechen würde er hatte ein
internationales netzwerk gesponnen er
hat in osteuropa kontakte in holland ist
jetzt festgenommen worden er war in
südamerika und deshalb ist eben die
befürchtungen hätte vielleicht noch
komplizen die noch mal raus holen weil
das weiß er für ihn geht es jetzt um
alles aber zynisch muss man eben auch
sagen selbst wenn er wieder raus käme
was will er machen er hat nichts anderes
gelernt als verbrecher vielen dank für
deine einschätzung frank schneider